In all of the examples that we
have seen so far, we have
calculated the distribution of a
random variable, Y, which is
defined as a function of another
random variable, X.
What about the case where we
define a random variable, Z,
as a function of multiple
random variables?
For example, here
is the function
of two random variables.
How can we find a distribution
of Z?
The general methodology
is exactly the same.
We somehow calculate the CDF of
the random variable Z and
then differentiate
to find its PDF.
Let us illustrate
this methodology
with a simple example.
So suppose that X and Y are
independent random variables
and each one of them is uniform
on the unit interval.
So their joint distribution is
going to be a uniform PDF on
the unit square.
We're interested in the random
variable, which is defined as
the ratio of Y divided by X.
So we will now calculate
the CDF of Z and then
differentiate.
It is useful to work in
terms of a diagram.
This is essentially our sample
space, the unit square.
The PDF of X is 1 on
the unit interval.
The PDF of Y is 1 on
Because of independence, the
joint PDF is the product of
their individual PDFs.
So the joint PDF is equal to 1
throughout this unit square.
So now let us write an
expression for the CDF of Z,
which, by definition, is the
probability that the random
variable Z, which in our case
is Y divided by X, is less
than or equal than a certain
number, little z.
What is the probability
of this event?
Let us consider a few
different cases.
Suppose that z is negative.
What is the probability that
this ratio is negative?
Well, since X and Y are
non-negative numbers, there's
no way that the ratio is
going to be negative.
So if little z is a negative
number, the probability of
this event is going
to be equal to 0.
This is the easier case.
Now suppose that z is
a positive number.
Let us draw a line that has
a slope of little z.
y/z being less than or equal
to little z is the same as
saying that y is less than or
equal to little z times x.
This is the line on which
y is equal to z times x.
So below that line, y is going
to be less than or
equal to z times x.
So the event of interest is
actually this triangle here.
And the probability of this
event, since we're dealing
with a uniform distribution on
the unit square, is just the
area of this triangle.
Now, since this line rises at
slope z, this point here, this
intercept is at z.
And so the sides of the
triangle are 1 and z.
And so this formula here gives
us the value of the CDF for
the case where little
z is positive.
And the same formula would also
be true if z also were
equal to 0, in which case,
we get 0 probability.
But is this correct for
all positive z's?
Well, not really.
This calculation was based
on this picture.
And in this picture, this line
intercepted this side of the
unit square.
And for that to happen, this
slope must be less than or
equal to 1.
So this formula is only correct
in the case where we
have a slope of less
than or equal to 1.
And now we need to deal with
the remaining case in which
little z is strictly
larger than 1.
In this case, we get a somewhat
different picture.
If we draw a line with slope,
again, little z, because
little z is bigger than 1, it's
going to intercept this
side of the rectangle.
Now, the event that Y/X is less
than or equal to little z
is, again, the event that the
pair, X, Y, lies below this
line that has a slope of z.
So all we need is to find
the area of this region.
One way of finding the area of
this region is to take the
area of the entire unit square,
which is equal to 1,
and subtract the area
of this triangle.
What is the area of
this triangle?
Well, since this line has a
slope of z, in order for it to
rise to a value of 1, x must be
equal to 1 over little z.
Therefore, this side of
the triangle is 1/z.
And therefore, the area of the
triangle is 1/2 times 1/z,
which is this expression here.
And so we have found the value
of the CDF for all possible
choices of little z.
We can draw the CDF.
And the picture is as follows.
For z negative, the
CDF is equal to 0.
For z between 0 and 1, the
CDF rises linearly
at a slope of 1/2.
And so when z is equal to
1, the CDF has risen
to a value of 1/2.
And then as z goes to infinity,
this term disappears
and the CDF will
converge to 1.
So it converges to 1
monotonically but in a
non-linear fashion.
So we get a picture
of this type.
The next step, the final step,
is to differentiate the CDF
and obtain the PDF.
In this region, the CDF is
constant, so its derivative is
going to be equal to 0.
In this region, the CDF is
linear, so its derivative is
equal to this factor of 1/2.
So the CDF is equal to 1/2
for z's between 0 and 1.
And finally, in this
region, this is the
formula for the CDF.
When we take the derivative, we
get the expression 1 over
2z squared, which is a function
that decreases as z
goes to infinity.
So it has a shape
like this one.
So we have completed the
solution to this problem.
We found the CDF, and we found
the corresponding PDF.
This methodology works more
generally for more complicated
functions of X and Y and for
more complicated distributions
for X and Y. Of course, when
the functions or the
distributions are more
complicated, the calculus
involved and the geometry may
require a lot more work.
But conceptually,
the methodology
is exactly the same.